all right I first want to begin I want
to welcome everyone to this program
maybe including some of you maybe they
don't usually tune in here those who
maybe now realize that you have been
lied to by other networks and the news
media on a spectacular level for years
and years you know I look at so-called
competition in cable news let's start
with Rachel Maddow saw daeun stay have
been sold one conspiracy theory night
after night after night why night after
night after night 22 months she has
profited from these lies to her audience
on a spectacular level frankly she and
her so-called colleagues so-called
mainstream media so-called journalists
they should be embarrassed tonight they
should feel humiliated tonight they
should be apologizing tonight to the
American people as well as so many
others in the media it will take me
months but we will follow every lead and
we will remind you what has been done
here now the truth has been laid bare
for all to see no collusion no
obstruction no truth to the lies that
have been peddled daily we on this
program have been right all along
because unlike the mainstream media we
have been telling the truth with
evidence to back it up many of you since
yesterday have been writing me and you
want me to spike the football tonight I
am NOT in any type of celebratory mood
here tonight in any way this is a time
every American that now knows truth you
should be angry at what has happened
here all of America I am pissed off and
so should the rest of the country be
over what has happened just because you
know this is the this is only the first
chapter this must be a day of reckoning
for the media for the deep state for
people who abused abuse power and they
did it so blatantly in this country if
we do not get this right if we do not
hold these people accountable I promise
you with all the love I can muster for
this country in our future for our kids
and grandkids we will lose the greatest
country God has ever given man
we will lose it we now have 675 days
twenty five plus million dollars twenty
eight hundred subpoenas five hundred
witnesses five hundred search warrants
door doors kicked down pre-dawn raids
felony convictions were processed crimes
screws turn to accelerate or hope for or
get people to lie to hurt the president
other lives ruined mounting legal bills
for so many Americans many who are now
facing bankruptcy like lieutenant
general Flynn a 33 year combat veteran
that's how we repay him and after a
prior nine month FBI investigation that
found zero evidence of Trump Russia
collusion after a bipartisan Senate
investigation found zero evidence of
collusion the press never told you after
another investigation in the house found
zero evidence of collusion lo and behold
for the fourth time we learned - over
the weekend Robert Muller has found zero
evidence of Trump Russia collusion
according to the Attorney General Bob
bars summary findings of the Muller
report quote the special counsels
investigation did not find that the
Trump campaign or anyone associated with
a conspired or coordinated with Russia
in its efforts to influence the 2016 US
presidential election and let me be
clear a direct quote from the Muller
report the investigation did not
establish that members of the Trump
campaign conspired coordinated with the
Russian government in its election
interference activities and that's not
all
president Trump has also been cleared of
the issue of obstruction of justice you
just heard from Jay Sekulow
Muller did not draw a conclusion quote
one way or another as to whether the
examined conduct constituted obstruction
the special counsel did not conclude
that the president committed a crime it
didn't exonerate him which the media is
clinging on to but read a little further
after reviewing the matter the Attorney
General in consultation with the Deputy
Attorney General who started this whole
thing rod Rosen Stein concluded quote
the key phrase that the media misses the
evidence developed there in the space
councils investigation is not sufficient
to establish that the president
committed an obstruction of justice
offense and this is a poor important
according to the Attorney General quote
our determination was made without
regard to and is not based on the
constitutional considerations that
surround the indictment and criminal
prosecution of a sitting president and
he concluded quote generally speaking to
obtain and sustain an obstruction
conviction the government would need to
prove beyond a reasonable doubt that a
person acting with corrupt intent
engaged in obstructive obstructive
conduct with a sufficient nexus to a
pending or contemplated proceeding
anyone in the media who refuses to admit
this truth is continuing the lying that
they have been involved in for two years
in other words you can obstruct a crime
you didn't commit
there was no collusion there cannot be
any obstruction no charges will be filed
the Muller Media witch-hunt is finally
over the big question for this country
tonight this shouldn't be about
conservative Liberal Democrat Republican
where do we as a country go from here
how do we prevent this unprecedented
attack on a duly elected president and
an effort to then overturn the will of
the American people from ever happening
again people with the highest levels of
power abusing that power to exonerate
one candidate that we know should have
been indicted to favor that candidate to
rig a presidential election and then
undo the results that they didn't like
after all you we the American people we
were lied to over and over and over
again my promise to this country from
this night forward is we will hold every
liar every propaganda every conspiracy
theorist accountable this will likely
take us months and maybe longer to
unravel the truth we've got all the tape
we've got all the comments it will take
time but I make you this pledge tonight
every deep state actor that abused the
power that you We the People give them
will be held accountable we will hold
every
super Patriot Comey who thought they
knew better than the American people
accountable we will hold every fake news
media liar conspiracy theorist
accountable we will hold every liar oh
the cowardly shift to begin with in
Congress accountable we will name names
we will demand new investigations we
will get this right we will demand that
we get this right and we will show you
who can never be trusted again and
tonight we start with this corrupt media
mob in the Democratic Party we now know
they work in unison they are one entity
and for the past two years there have
been two parallel narratives in this
country one of course was the truth
which we have been proving night after
night and reporting on night after night
and tomorrow all the people that deserve
the credit will be here with me about
the biggest abuse of power corruption
scandal perhaps in history and then
there was the media's pack of lies about
a grand scheme where Donald Trump and
his team work closely with Russia to
steal the election literally breathless
reporting hysteria pushed week after
week every second every hour of every
day look at some headlines Vox were
commonplace across nearly every media
outlet there's actually lots of evidence
of Trump Russia collusion wrong the
Atlantic the collusion with Russia is in
plain sight wrong Huffington Post ran
this lie on their front page Matt afford
indictment reveals Trump Russia
collusion a lie we're talking about
thousands upon thousands of reports in
the opinion and so-called hard news
pages alike that means the Washington
Post the New York Times believe it or
not they actually won Pulitzer Prizes
for they're lying coverage of the Russia
collusion hoax that is a disgusting
disgrace and a dishonor to every person
that deserved a real Pulitzer Prize this
horrible conspiratorial coverage was
amplified every single day on fake News
CNN conspiracy TV MSNBC this is but just
a tiny sampling take a look I think this
meeting and the revelations about it are
a game changer in the
station because they present the first
evidence of actual collusion what mr.
Trump did yesterday was to betray the
women men of the FBI the CIA NSA and
others and to betray the American public
and that's why I used the term that this
is nothing short of treasonous this is
direct collusion collusions been
established it's out in the open
right we know this all took place and
the whole notion there being no
collusion this is the biggest diversion
of the Trump crowd there was collusion
so this picture that the president is so
desperate to avoid this picture of
collusion begins to fill in you know
that's interesting here is it's both on
one hand very damning because it's
collusion you see it there in its
closure if it seemed that collision is
obvious a criminal conspiracy is
collusion in plain sight there were the
back-and-forth between various
individuals who were affiliated with the
Trump campaign and Russian individuals
that collusion I think is quite obvious
and apparent i political hurricane is
out there and see for him we'll call it
hurricane vladimer if you will the whole
Russian thing this is evidence of
willingness to commit collusion this is
all a lie and at the height of this
hysteria especially fake news CNN and
conspiracy TV MSNBC oh of course they
were featuring every second of every day
former stormy Daniels attorney Michael
avenatti more than a hundred and eight
times in two months because he hated
Donald Trump and avenatti was
speculating wildly and spreading these
baseless rumors and they ate it up about
Trump and Russia on a daily nightly
basis well today avenatti was indicted
in two federal separate cases
surrounding fraud and extortion yet for
weeks avenatti was their star guest on
cable TV on show after show after show
and the media was desperate for the
false narrative and lied to be advanced
you know britt hume fifty years in
journalism called this russia collusion
coverage the worst journalistic debacle
of his lifetime over fifty years in
journalism i thought i had a lot of
thirty you know even far left former
Rolling Stones writer Matt Taibbi I
think is his name quote nobody wants to
hear this but news that
special prosecutor Muller is headed home
without issuing new charges is a death
blow for the reputation of the American
news media Jeff Zucker head of CNN are
you going to apologize for your networks
constant stream of lies and hysteria
Phil Griffin NBC are you going to
apologize for the conspiracy theories
you allow to be spread every second of
every day on NBC what about Jeff Bezos
Marty Baron are you going to come clean
over the front page deception every day
in the Washington Post will you at least
stop referring to far-left collusion of
sex-obsessed hack Jennifer Rubin and
others as conservatives they're not is
the New York Times executive editor Dean
back when is he gonna give back the
papers Pulitzer Prize for collusion
reporting given they were caught now
reporting a hoax they all lied to We the
People day after day for two-plus years
in reality we know there will never be a
mayor coppa from any of these major fake
news outlets let's move on to the next
group of lies he'll never apologize
they'll never retract their lies their
anonymous sourcing their endless
speculation they are hopeless journalism
I told you in 2007 it's dead it's buried
and it's not something that I said
lightly they have earned their horrible
reputations never vetted Obama they
rushed the judgment going back to
Richard Jewell look what they did to a
16 year old kid and other 16 year olds
from Covington Nicholas Sandman and the
Covington kids look at what they did in
the Smollett case look what they did to
the Cambridge police Darren Wilson
Michael Brown in Ferguson Freddie gray
they rushed the judgment in Baltimore
the fake rape allegations at UVA the
fake rape allegations against the Duke
lacrosse team the rule of law be damned
due process be damned equal justice be
damned under the law equal application
of our laws be damned the Constitution
of the United States to all of them be
damned the media mob the Democratic
Party mob they have caused great harm
and division in this country they
laughed at the idea that
Donald Trump could win they begged him
to run by the way on all those cases we
mentioned we didn't rush to judgment
justice Cavanaugh another case we allow
due process we allowed the presumption
of innocence they never allowed it in
any of those cases and they've never
been held accountable but it's never
been this big now that he's president
they have never taken the time to ever
cover Donald Trump's accomplishments
which have been record-breaking they
hate him they hate all of we the people
that dared to vote for him they thought
they knew better
we the irredeemable deplorable 'he's you
know that we believe in God our Bibles
our religion
we're the smelly Walmart shoppers this
hatred is now this rage has caused the
mainstream media to be wrong over and
over and over and over and over again
NPR embarrassed after it lied about Todd
juniors Senate testimony oh we pay for
their coverage McClatchy blatantly wrong
about Michael cones trip to Prague it
never happened
The Guardian reporting of fake
conspiracy about Muller and Julian
Assange 3 CNN employees forced to resign
after reporting and untrue Russia's
story related about Anthony scaramouche
II our friend fake news story after fake
news story lie after lie propaganda
after propaganda if it had to do with
Russia President Trump while the story
was hastily reported and facts were
nothing more than an afterthought look
at more of the video evidence a sort of
dossier of alleged dirt that the
Russians allegedly say they allegedly
have on Donald Trump alleged dirt that
they allegedly used to allegedly
cultivate him is basically a Russian
asset you get the person's phone records
here they see these calls to the block
number and now there seems to be good
evidence that that was probably
president Trump Michael Cohen claims
that then candidate Donald Trump knew in
advance about the June 2016 meeting in
Trump Tower crucially these sources tell
us that Cohen is willing to make that
assertion to the special counsel Robert
Muller
we begin with a new report that Paul man
afford the president's former campaign
chairman paid secret visits multiple
ones to Julian Assange at the Ecuadorian
Embassy in London this is according to
the Guardian president Trump directed
his attorney to lie to Congress
why no due process why no presumption of
innocence why no due diligence even on a
16 year old kid blatant false reporting
rushing to judgment again and again the
answer is simple this corrupt partisan
media mob is an integral part of the new
radical extreme democratic socialist
party they clearly work together they
develop they push the same narrative
using the same words whether it is true
or not
outlets like fake News CNN conspiracy TV
NBC they have become nothing more than
the propaganda arm of the Democratic
Party that's why when they try to kill
us here at Fox and you support us you
are you are allowing the only voice of
reason on the air half the time that's
why Democrats the media sounded exactly
alike remember their comments about
collusion gee they sound like one
another it's like they're one mind one
heart one body one soul take a look
you know my Republican colleagues the
President himself the White House has
been saying there's no evidence of
collusion none at all we need people to
say that there's no evidence of
collusion no collusion at whatsoever
well it turns out that it was there was
collusion in our investigation we saw
strong evidence of collusion the
Republicans now are choosing to Berrien
over the course of the last year we have
seen I think a mountain of evidence of
collusion between the campaign and the
Russians the evidence is pretty clear
that there was collusion between the
Trump campaign and the Russians and
evidence is pretty clear the the
evidence is there it seems quite clear
that president keeps saying no collusion
but there obviously was collusion and
the question is how high that collusion
went and whether the president was part
of a criminal conspiracy there was
clearly a criminal conspiracy to defraud
the American people of an honest
election this looks like an explosive
indictment because the facts they set
forth look
by collusion we saw cold hard evidence
of the Trump campaign indeed the Trump
family eagerly intending to collude
possibly with Russia all lies in the end
we now know the truth
Trump Russia collusion the conspiracy
theory was nothing more than a coping
mechanism by people that couldn't handle
losing desperately hoping the 2016
election results were not what they were
some evil force was behind the scenes
behind the curtain pulling the strings
Russia Russia Russia never before as a
country have we witnessed such
sore-loser ISM ever like this so many
lies so much hysteria and breathless
reporting and democratic health Intel
Committee Chairman shift I call him the
Cowardly shift lied repeatedly when he
said there's significant evidence of
collusion he is not to be trusted
should be taken off as the chairman of
the House Intelligence Evod to impeach
Trump over collusion you can never trust
people that lied like this or
congressman Eric saw well who said he's
seen plenty of evidence of collusion he
is a liar
he's never to be trusted or senator
Hirono exclaiming that we are headed
towards a constitutional crisis more
total BS and the list goes on and on and
the hysteria and the left was widespread
in fact if not for talk radio thank God
for rush mark my colleagues here many of
them at the Fox News Channel like Tucker
Laura Lou Dobbs on our sister station
Fox & Friends a few other brave logical
independent thinkers standing alone
there would have been no one out there
advocating for the truth
discovering the biggest abuse of power
scandal in our history nobody we now
have to concern ourselves as a country
with a two-tiered system of justice
featuring high-ranking deep state
powerful officials we empower the
that tried to first rigged an election
in favor of Hillary Clinton by
exonerating her from what should have
been obvious obstruction and a violation
of the Espionage Act then they use their
power to try and influence the 2016
election with Russian lies that Hillary
paid for of all
irony's that's why our Hannity watch on
the deep state is more important than
ever I am tonight wearing an FBI flag
pin given to me by a rank-and-file FBI
individual can't name them he'll get in
trouble but like so many people I know
in the FBI thanking me for
distinguishing between the 99% of brave
dedicated agents of the premier law
enforcement agency of the world that do
a tremendous job that are embarrassed by
what their leadership has done and they
serve our country every day don't put
them in the same alignment if you will
with the commis and mccabe struck in
pages of the world and this is now time
that we get the justice that we deserve
this is now time for those that Bews the
power that you gave them their day of
reckoning must now come or else this
will happen again my sources are telling
me it's all about to come cascading down
this all started when they rigged the
investigation into Hillary's emails
scandal there was clear compelling
incontrovertible evidence that in fact
she mishandled top-secret classified
information on a private server that we
believe six foreign intelligence
agencies broke into there was clear
evidence by the way no attorney could
get me or any of you out of you know
subpoena the emails that you may destroy
33,000 of them and then you acid wash
your harddrive with bleach pit and you
bang up your phones and your your
devices with hammers and remove the SIM
cards members struck and page and their
text remember about Trump supporters
they said were smelly Walmart people and
saying that Hillary should win a hundred
million to zero
the lead investigator into the Clinton
case struck who did the interview with
Flynn and Clinton and the Clinton case
imagine allowing to over Fran
in the room while she's being
interrogated in an investigation or as
Loretta Lynch said a matter he was
writing Hillary's exoneration with
commis blessing in May of 2016 they had
never done an investigation the
exoneration before the investigation by
the way interviewed her July 2nd Comey
exonerated her July 5th but not before
Cheryl Mills was granted immunity not
before the infamous tarmac meeting
between Bill Clinton and then attorney
general Lynch and of course the
testimony last week that Loretta Lynch
herself was up to our eyeballs in every
decision that was made and even Lisa
page admitted well they're all Democrats
we knew the fix was in that horribly
flawed investigation into the Hillary
Clinton now must be reopened if we are
to ever have justice in this country
once Clinton lost the election the next
phase of the deep state corruption that
kicked in you know the insurance policy
Hillary's bought and paid for Russian
lies imagine Russian lies put together
by a foreign spy and then used on an
American citizen to get entry into the
entire Trump campaign in the lead up to
a presidential election they night
tonight Carter page due process they
denied Carter pages constitutional
rights they repeatedly committed fraud
against FISA Court judges they did it by
omission by not disclosing that Hillary
bought and paid for the Russian lies and
of course they used what is unverified
uncorroborated information because
remember Christopher steel doesn't stand
by it to this day
remember Bruce or warned everybody this
was in October 2016 that dossier was
tainted Hillary paid for it Christopher
steel hated Trump and Christopher steel
testified I'm only 50 50 percent it's
raw intelligence as to whether any of
the dossier was true most of it now was
debunked that rendered that dossier
unverifiable they say they tried to
verify it they're lying and that didn't
stop the dossier from them being used as
Nunez and the Grassley grab memo said is
the bulk of evidence to get the FISA
warrants four of them so tonight it's
time for transparency tonight we begin a
process that will take us a long time of
accountability we begin it is now time
to declassify all
those FISA applications you talk about
transparency let the American people see
the extent to which those FISA warrants
were based on Hillary's bought and paid
for
Russian lies and then fully exposed
every single one of these deep state
actors who abuse the power that you the
American people gave them James Comey
let's start with him let's start with
Sally Yates they need to be investigated
McCabe needs to be investigated all who
signed off on the FISA warrants need to
be fully investigated Susan Wright's
Samantha Power's John Brennan clapper
Lynch and also if Lynch is running this
whole fix what did Obama know and when
did he know it they all must be now put
under oath investigated because they
weaponized the powerful tools of
intelligence and resources and they
literally broke the law they surveilled
against the law they amassed Americans
and against the law they leaked raw
intelligence against the law and they
try to favor an election in in one side
and not the other and then bludgeon and
undo a presidential election clapper and
Brennan let's hold them accountable for
leaking in lying by the way call me oh
he believed in the and the dossier in
October 2016 but told Trump in January
of seventeen its salacious is not
verified what about the private memos he
purposefully leaked government documents
to a special counsel to begin the
investigation think about the harm that
all of this has done imagine what
President could withstand this denying a
free fair open election and the American
people their right to pick their
president the president and his
supporters an attempted frankly coup of
a sitting president appointing a special
counsel filled with partisan Democrats
people that went to Hillary's victory
party and even represented as attorneys
Hillary Clinton this has caused enormous
amounts of collateral damage to many
people that cannot afford the lawyers
they had to hire the president his wife
his kids his family his advisers heroes
like Michael Flynn people like Carter
page George papadopolis and so many
others and after Attorney General Barr
released the summary yesterday at the
Muller report
there's FBI director Comey tweeting so
many questions which Senator Lindsey
Graham replied couldn't agree with you
more see you soon I warned a director
called me a long time ago before his
book you have the right to remain silent
I suggest you use it you didn't take my
advice